ich kriege meine kopfhörer hier nicht
ein
herr cordes vorbei mittlerweile szene 34
sind schon ca 35 milliarden 1000 grad
draußen dem wollte sandra von einer
halben stunde hier sein podcast
aufnehmen müssen aber die ist noch immer
nicht da hast du nasse haare ja wirklich
sehr sehr traurig andere leute haben
eine normale schule oder song sandra ja
ich laufe auch in meiner wohnung um
facebook ich war ja nicht facebook
damals jetzt auf jeden fall weg meine
lieben freunde ich schneide jetzt mein
video und das ist wieder eines super
kameraperspektive
[Musik]
da ist jetzt weg ich schneide jetzt mein
video und danach lege ich mich in die
sauna tree
[Musik]
ich habe eine menge geschnitten übrigens
kein t shirt an weil 70.000 graz und
jeden fall habe ich ein bisschen wasser
getrunken und dann habe ich die flasche
alt wieder abgesetzt und dabei ist ein
kleiner tropfen runtergefahren auf mein
schreibstil war auch die nutzer auch
hier abdruck auf jeden fall ist es
mittlerweile 15 uhr 30 in drei stunden
kommen schon sandra jetzt ums studium
dann geben wir dem markt einkaufen weil
wir heute grillen werden und bis dahin
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
frei und werde mich ein bisschen sonnen
dann dürfen wir sie allerdings euch den
rechten von links vergessen nicht dass
man bekommt nur wenige minuten später
wirst du hast dir das auch allerdings
schon gemacht jetzt einkaufen zu sein
grillabend wenn man mir geht es nicht
gut
die antwort ist nein ich dachte da oben
stehen zwei leute aber das ist einfach
aufgebaut
so hast du mir aus sondern du hast keine
freunde das standard locken einkaufen
shop machen megacool der verabredung zum
grillen und es fängt an zu wissen viele
leute übrigens von einem unserer letzten
lauf abende einfach ein paar bilder
genommen ausdrücken aber nicht überall
super doll brille
wir wollen hier keinen content bieten
die laune ist wenn man keinen hat einer
genauen analyse wieder gefragt di luca
wir machen auf jeden fall da ich hier
der bürger sein kommt damit ich die
auftrag ich muss morgen lesen und
coaches interessiert aber hier und die
burger braten jetzt da vorne macht den
salat denn je macht die dingens viele
955 110 km h kann sich so richtig gut
gemacht ich bin fertig mit grillen habe
jetzt hier meinen bürger meinen salat
und die anderen sitzen am schluss
aufgegessen
der tod ist auf jeden fall gut
angekommen
ich meine freunde damit der challenge
überlegt dafür brauchen wir drei team wo
ich habe ja zum krank ist hätten wir
schon mal durchgemacht ich weiß nicht
wieso perfekt genau so macht man das
nicht wollt ihr wissen was es für eine
challenges
lassen wir es also wir sind jeweils in
zweierteams zu machen jungen ein mädchen
dementsprechend drei teams und man muss
sich in die augen schauen ganz davor in
anderen man muss sich gegenseitig
abwechselnd an stühlen
okay das war super hintergrund toren
waren die dicken warten erstmal
vergleich besonders machen und meine
wahl stellen trinken ist bei
leitungswasser und singen welche
betrunkenen krass jetzt habe ich auf
jeden fall content von ganzen block vor
allem wieder hier sitzen er mit seinen
hinterpfoten soll ich nicht beleidigen
willst du liegen bei mir und ändert sich
ja von glück oder was ich würde sie
nicht direkt aus dem glas essen mit den
händen du kurz danach jetzt hier mit
wodka und bier ganz kurz zu
entschuldigen
ich wollte mir schon mal ganz kurz dafür
entschuldigen die dumm und durcheinander
blockes
ich sehe ich dass freunde wo gekauft hat
keiner bei mir abgezogen reinschreiben
rheine
die scheiße gez da sagt herzig
wenn wir es gerade schon sagen ob die
neue werkstoffe getroffen rosen
diese harz am geldautomaten roma wohl
keiner von uns geld falle nicht die hier
mit kölsch gipfel
wir sind da wir gerade so mit 18 leuten
am laufen da hinten ist alles voll auch
mit leuten herum kommen und da und
einfach seine oma ich glaube die kapelle
zahlen stand schlafen
so laufen halt noch mal alle menschen da
macht man so halbe übersteiger weil sie
viele kranke biggs beide hardy aber ich
bin aber so he
sie leuchtet sie dass die kinder liefen
es ist vier uhr
die partys ende meine lieben freunde ich
habe selbstverständlich
natürlich natürlich hätte ich doch den
ganzen tag lugner flog dann fresse ich
zu haben so viel getrunken die kosten
okay wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
und ich hoffe man hört dass ich war
erstmal ein bisschen ihr licht an dem
gästezimmer
das habe ich kurz rein kommen ich gehe
jetzt auf jeden fall schlafen meine
lieben freu mich auf euch hat dieser
wenn auch sehr verstörende und
durcheinander sein blog gefallen ist das
getan hat das gern like da also daumen
runter sausen gekehrt so hoch liegt
jetzt auf dem verschlafen ich brauche
meinen schlaf mein schönheitsschlaf habe
ich trinke nun bin ich hier
[Musik]